hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from the european uh team
championship for men in 1965 so the
third altogether european championship
for men uh and it's a really really cool
game between david bronstein who you
guys know all too well he's the he's
been on this channel quite uh quite a
lot of times uh not just by his games
but also by his famous quotes and also i
mentioned uh from time to time i will
mention his great book about the siddiq
tournament of 1953 the the i think it's
called the the great international
tournament of story 1953. uh if you guys
can get that book do do get it because
your uh game will improve so much your
your opponents will just hate you uh
brunch and won the second place behind
vasilis mislove in that
tournament but the games there are just
incredible and the way he explains games
um
in that book just shows you how not even
grandmasters of that era really
understood what was happening in the
games how he explains it so really
really an awesome one uh do get it if
you get an opportunity here uh he faces
uh rudolph teshna uh he's a seven times
berlin champion and he's a very strong
player himself also a writer and he
faced mikkel tile uh some four times and
he even got a draw in one game so
definitely a strong player
and uh the game is just a wonderful no
surprises here it's uh forced mate in
nine uh that's what we're gonna be
looking for and the knight delivers it
as we uh as the title suggests so let's
check it out uh all right the uh pawn is
already on the board but i'm gonna move
it anyway so uh braunstein opens with e4
we have e5 uh knight to c3 knight to f6
and now g3 so going for the vienna game
this is the the the folk beer variation
of the vienna uh we have bishop to b4
and now bishop to g2 so nicely
developing so if the is captured the
pawn is defended but in positions like
these it's never a good idea to capture
this knight because queen e2 and then
you might run into some problems so d6
we have knight g to e2 and now c6 we
have castles by braunstein uh and teshna
goes for knight to knight b to d7 and it
is now as of move six that this position
has never been reached again so let's
see how braunstein continues we have d3
and now knight to f8 very standard uh in
these kind of positions three maneuver
your knight the knight can now come to
g6 it can come to e6 to control the d4
square so all depends on what uh white
plays with a3 asking black do you want
to capture or do you want to go back but
black already played c6 so the bishop
can go to a5 and then to c7 and then the
bishop pair will be
well almost fully operational the white
already castle king side so we could go
for some sort of a queen side attack if
at all possible so bishop to a5 white
pushes b4 against more space attacks the
bishop bishop to c7 and not even d4 uh
the king is still in the center of the
board so it definitely makes sense to
open up the center queen to e7 and now
we have queen to d3 now we have to
develop the bishop connect our rooks and
then we are we are good to go we have h5
now uh and with this move black now says
i'm not gonna be castling king side most
likely i want to play h4 open up the h
file for my rook and like i said i have
these two beautiful bishops here uh
going after your king so this is what
i'm hoping for and after the slight
square bishop moves i might even castle
queen side maybe try and shift the over
the other rook over to the king side to
help out with the attack so here we have
h3 uh h for now and of course g4 keeping
the position closed but black did
achieve this weakening of the position
in in white's king's side so here bishop
to d7 now black might be considering
castling queen side and now braunstein
says uh pawn to f4
and here branson is just asking black
what are you really doing here are you
attacking are you defending are you
gonna go to the queen side because it it
doesn't seem to be working out all that
well
you kind of are attacking but you're
really not because if you capture i'm
just gonna capture with my knight and
now for example you castle queen side b5
and it's white who's attacking we can
capture here our bishop is a monster we
can play rook to b1 just bring the rook
to help out with the attack even queen
to a6 can maybe be happen at some point
so it would be very very hard for black
to survive this position uh so instead
black goes knight to e6 puts pressure on
the f4 pawn and bronzon continues
development bishop to e3
so now uh black has a different plan now
black captures on f4 braunstein
recaptures and now knight the g5 but
this knight will be a big big problem
for black as you'll see now branston has
a couple of ways of handling this
position one is to take advantage of the
knight on g5 being undefended right away
with a move like knight f to d5 attacks
the queen opens up and attack towards
the knight and here we would see
probably something crazy like knight
captures an h3 check bishop captures and
c captures on d5
and it seems like uh you know anything
can happen here but white after bishop
to g5 really has uh has an excellent
position and it's hard for black to even
make a move here for example if black
does something uh
weak like d captures an e4 you can
simply capture and there's no capturing
because just rotate the e1 and it's a
game over
so very easy for black to go wrong but
braunschweig first prepares it first
rook a to e1 like we've seen that line
rook 8 to e1 clinches that entire
combination so he starts with that and
now we know that this is definitely the
threat and if uh tesna doesn't do
anything about this it's gonna be big
problems for black so of course black
castles queen side uh but this doesn't
work out all that well uh so now
braunschweig starts the attack with b5
he said you pushed your pawns here on
the king side you made your attack uh
you know last uh for a few moves but now
it's white who's attacking and there's
really no good way to counter this you
can't really capture the pawn here if
you capture the pawn uh we we can
capture back we can play knight after d5
because we've now freed up the uh d5
square for a knight we attacked the
black queen the knight and it's uh it's
a really tough position if captures
captures just you're gonna eliminate the
bishop you're gonna
uh for force the queen to move the
knight here is still hanging so the
queen does not have any squares left to
keep defending that knight so it's uh
just uh
you know complete annihilation uh what
you could do after b5 is maybe try
something like kink to b8 but that also
doesn't really work b captures on c6 and
if bishop captures again knight after d5
we don't really care this knight will
not fall knight captures on d5 we're
gonna play e captures on d5 so uh
we have to force black to choose between
pieces so now the bishop is attacked and
of course after the bishop moves we
still uh just move to bishop for example
bishop d to open up a discovery and you
can't keep uh defending this knight
because the rooks are controlling the e7
and the f6 squares the queen moves and
we're going to pick up the knight so
this knight to g5 really is giving black
a huge headache so here black tried to
go for the counter attack black tried
knight captures on g4
but braunstein just doesn't care okay if
you capture the knight didn't black
probably play something like h3 and this
is still good for white but
there's no need to go to to allow black
anything so after knight captures on g4
we have b captures in c6 and now we have
to react to this because this would fall
with with uh check so b captures on c6
if you try bishop captures then again
knight after d5 simply remove the
defender of the knight here queen moves
and then we pick up
the knight on g5 so this is constantly
in the position so after b captures on
c6 uh d captures and c sorry b captures
on c6 we have b captures on c6 by tesna
uh and now uh it's uh time for the
famous mate in nine and uh keep in mind
you have to calculate all the way to the
end the knight delivers checkmate
feel free to pause the video and solve
this position while i give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations uh yes uh the first
move starts with a check it's not as
great uh as you know when the first move
doesn't start with the check but still
it's you know it's uh quite quite enough
so congratulations to everyone who
spotted this and to all of you who just
want to enjoy the show queen to a6 check
and i'm sure all of you thought about
this move so king the b8 we have to
defend this is the only move that we can
play there is no other move so king to
b8 now rook to b1 with check of course
black has to block if you just move the
king queen to b7 is checkmate so we have
to block with bishop to b6 and now of
course the move you all saw rook
captures on b6 now again you can't move
the king queen b7 is checkmate so the
rook sacrifice has to be accepted we
have eight captures on b6 and now queen
captures on b6 with check and it was
actually in this position on move 23
that rudolph tesna resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here to
finish the game and show everyone what
all of you found uh the idea is of
course that if you go to a8 then it's a
very simple uh checkmate so this is not
the one that we're looking for we're
always looking for uh the one with the
most resilient uh uh defense from the
defending side here just queen a6 check
king to b8 we're gonna play rook to b1
check queen c7 king c7 and queen b7 will
be checkmate but that's not the one that
we're looking for the one that we're
looking for is that uh after the king
goes to c8 so now we play queen to a6
check but now of course the king doesn't
go to b8 the king goes to c7 and now it
seems like black might be able to play
rogue b8 and escape with the king
however now the two knights really come
in handy knight after d5 with check and
this has to be accepted there is no
other way it does come with a royal fork
but we don't really care about that uh
pawn captures and now we come uh capture
with the other knight again a royal fork
so two royal forks in a row this is not
something you see very often in chess uh
king the b8 only move there is no other
move and only now queen b6 check and now
you leave black the option of playing
king k8 or king to c7 the king to see it
but wherever black goes it's the knight
that delivers checkmate so after king to
a8 knight to c7 would be checkmate and
of course uh if the king goes to c8 then
we pick up the queen but only to deliver
checkmate we really don't care about
this queen so it would if the game
continued it'd be even nicer if it
finished like this you know so you know
if you won the queen and checkmate your
opponent then no one really cares but if
it's a position like this uh then you
know people will say oh it's a
masterpiece uh so yeah that's
uh that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it 23 moves but 28 actually uh
really hope a lot of you tried to pause
this one and find it because you had
everything you had like the the starting
check then you had to sacrifice the
exchange and then you'd have to
sacrifice both of the knights uh to then
you know
one of the nights to deliver a checkmate
with the other night regardless of what
black plays
so yeah
that's uh the game hope you guys enjoyed
it uh congratulations once again to
everyone who found that and hope you
guys had fun in the in delicious arena i
will try to organize some more of them
it's been a while since i've done that
but uh
you know hopefully i will be able to uh
do do do more of them uh you know soon
uh so yeah once again uh i really hope
you guys enjoyed it i would like to
thank tony mo at guitar kevin schmidl uh
andy flint eduardo the american flag
iglesias and danny green for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and of course
whatever else is happening in the chess
world so thank you i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day